here on a Friday morning it's the last
day of school before winter break for
CCSD and today hundreds of Rundle
Elementary School students are going to
get some free toys and free food it's
because of the heart to heart holiday
give back event and our Candace Charles
Candace Claus joining us live from the
school with the people behind this big
donation good morning
good morning YouTube good morning folks
Kansas Clause has something in her bag
but honestly it's a community that put
this all together look at all of these
toys a small portion of what some of the
students will get to pick through today
we've got treats for them as well and
I'm joined by their principal the
wonderful Dr Lynette Reese thank you so
much for joining us this morning tell us
why this is such a special day for your
students and their families our students
get Christmas today they get a gift they
get a treat is going to be the most
amazing day ever tell us a little bit
about the community here so we are a 100
Title One School 100 free lunch we have
a lot of need here we have about a third
of our students are homeless and but we
have the best students in the entire
school district and the best principal
absolutely and I'm joined by the Mind
behind all the heart behind it all
Ashley Bernie thank you so much for
joining us Heart to Heart first time you
guys are doing this tell us why you
decide to do it so these kids are
amazing they their their need does not
stop who they're becoming it does not
stop their energy and so to be able to
have our program and to know those
students for several years now it's just
a joy to have the community come
together for such a great event amazing
and she partnered with several
organizations to make this all happen
students will get toy maybe two and some
snacks today and she's really known them
for so long because she's been a part of
the mentorship program and I hear that
they need more mentors definitely a lot
of great work that these two ladies are
doing thank you so much for chatting
with me this morning you can find out
more about heart to heart as well as the
mentorship program here on website
newsnow.com this is all kicking off this
morning students will start coming here
at 11 it's going to be a beautiful
morning right as they head into the
winter holiday for now live for merchant
rental Elementary School Candace Charles
or Kent's Claus eight news now